in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Mike
and Ashley are with us from Asheville
North Carolina welcome you all I was in
your fair state last evening I got in
about midnight we were at an event in
Raleigh Durham and okay
been to Asheville many times beautiful
area welcome to Nashville thank you
you're here to do it that free scream
yeah yes love it how much have you paid
off at two hundred and forty seven
thousand dollars whoa
how long did that take about thirty
three months okay and range of income
during that time well so we started off
at I started off alone I had not yet met
Mike at $115,000 and then we met and we
agreed to be on your plan together and
so we ended up at two hundred and ten
thousand dollars at the end Wow what do
you guys do for a living I'm a
pharmacist and I work in human resources
good very cool good for you guys
phenomenal well done well our Human
Resources guys are all in the back
parking lot getting knocked off at
Jeff's and so yeah and they're also
worried about liability at the same time
so that's you know the you know the
Guidry yeah absolutely
fun so that's a lot of dad it's but
you're a pharmacist so I'm guessing
student loans and how much of the 247
was that it was $150,000 okay so all but
100k roughly and what was the other 100k
a couple cars and his condominium okay
paid off his condominium mm-hmm does
that mean you live in your place or what
yes are we rent right oh you rent and
you ever paid for condo
we sold the console married okay all
right and what did it bring about let me
see fifty fifty two thousand dollars
okay so that was part of the equation
getting rid of two hundred fifty
thousand and thirty three months yes cuz
I mean you guys make a lot of money but
that's a lot to pay off in two and a
half years about three years all those
but yeah still pretty stinking
incredible congratulations thank you so
you've been married just under three
years or nine months nine months last
July okay so you're both working on it
as singles and then when you got married
you combined your effort right yes so
several years ago my brother started
your plan and he told me about it and
that
listen to that and my plan wasn't
working so I decided to listen to your
plan and I agreed with your plan and
then I got engaged
proposed to me again before we got
married I wanted us to have a plan for
our finances and so I told him about
your plan he agreed and so we took FPU
you make that sound so simple there was
no conflict Mike you weren't like
kidding it took me a bit to cover the
credit cards and those things but it was
pretty well on my own financial peace
and coming into her system you're
looking at her student loans going yeah
we got there something you're pretty but
that's a lot of that's that's fine very
cool
well congratulations so nine months
you've been at this hard core together
and totally knit together as far as that
part goes so how does this equation of
intensity on a plan on knocking out debt
how does that work in the first year of
marriage well I really think that it's
working on our finances together it's
helped us with all of our other
conflicts you know we have to sit down
together work out a budget work out
where we want our money to go and the
ultimate goal with our money is to be
able to you know give it away and give
it up to the glory of God yeah so you
know once we have that other conflicts
seem pretty easy so I did it helped it
didn't hurt right during the first year
yeah and we paid it up pretty early and
once we sold the condo that was the that
wiped it last a bit of way so okay so
that closing was whoa yes yes absolutely
very very cool good good okay so all
this sounds so sweet and nice what was
the biggest fight you had you remember
one good one we're so perfect as a
couple some way they've got to be able
to work I mean my gosh you're beautiful
you
you make great money you're just perfect
you're just sweet it's awesome it's good
well take it I wanted to show you this
okay so I whenever I had so much debt
you know you write down the number and
it's pretty bad
so I got a calendar in each year I would
write down how much more I didn't have
to pay off said write down my amount
down here and each week I would try to
pay off okay my loans so this is what I
kept and October the 26th it was gone
you know and I notice every page is the
Caribbean I'm thinking white beaches are
in your future okay that's a good you
gotta have a calendar it's got a goal on
it I mean you wouldn't want a calendar
with pictures of garbage dumps I mean
you'd want yeah that's what we want
we're gonna be on the beach there that's
exhume azure something like that that
looks pretty cool yeah nice first time I
saw it I thought she was a little crazy
but I got I got over it and it's all
part of the package so yeah you know
that's how you win with this you got to
get a little crazy a little OCD about it
and your friends think you're crazy
people make fun of y'all not really you
know we had our family support and you
know nobody really now that they weren't
that number there they got to be going
how did you do that yeah very cool well
congratulations you guys are fun very
very well done thanks for coming all the
way over from Asheville your hero's your
heroes you decide to write your own
story Mike and Ashley from Asheville
North Carolina two hundred and forty
thousand dollars paid off in thirty
three months making a hundred and
fifteen to two hundred and ten a year
after they're married for the last nine
months count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three
well Don you guys well done well done
I love it love it I love it I love it
very well done
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you